withdrawal
of u.s troops from afghanistan
uh what are your thoughts on how that
was executed
how could it have been done better
yeah an important question
i mean i would preface all this by
saying
you know as i noted i think the war was
a mistake um
i
had hoped the war would end sooner i
think there were
different exit routes all along the way
again i think there were
lots of policy choices
in september in october when the war
began
um there were choices in december 2001
so we could
look at almost every six month stopping
point and say
we could have done differently
as it turns out though i mean the way it
played out um you know it's been
catastrophic and i think
the body administration
has remained unaccountable for the scale
of
the strategic and humanitarian and
ethical failure that they're responsible
for
well okay let's lay out the full
there's george w bush there's
barack obama there's donald trump that's
right there is uh
biden yeah
uh so they're all driving this van and
there's these exits and they keep not
taking the exits and they're running out
of gas yeah i do this all the time
thinking where am i going to pull off
i'll go to perfect till it's empty how
could it have been done
better and what exactly
um
how much suffering
have
all the decisions along the way caused
what are the long-term consequences what
are the biggest things that concern you
about the decisions we have made in both
invading afghanistan and staying in
afghanistan as long as we have
i mean if we start at the end as you
proposed um
yeah the horrific scenes of the airport
you know that was just one one dimension
um
i think in the weeks to come
[Music]
i mean we're going to see afghanistan
implode
there are lots of signs that
malnutrition hunger starvation
are going to claim
tens of thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of lives this winter
and i think there is really
nothing
there's no
framework in place to
force all that
what is the government
what is currently the system there
what's the role the taliban so there
could be tens of thousands hundreds of
thousands that starve
uh
either just
almost the famine or starve to death
so this is economic implosion this is
political implosion what
um what's the system they're like and
what could be the one you know some
inkling of hope right right
the talbots sit in control that's unique
when they were in power in the 1990s
from
1996 2001 they controlled
some 85 to 90 of the country
now they own it all
uh but they have no budget
the afghan
banking system
is
frozen
so the financial system is a mess and
it's frozen by the us because the us
is trying to use that lever to exert
pressure on the taliban
and so the ethical quandaries are of
course legion right
do you release that money
to allow the taliban to shore up their
rule right
the body administration has said no
but
the banks aren't working
uh if you're in california you want to
send 100 to your cousin so
she can buy bread you can't do that now
it's almost impossible there are some
informal networks they're moving some
stuff
but there are bread lines the talbot
government is incapable
fundamentally just of ruling i mean they
they can discipline people on the street
they can force people into the mosque
they can shoot people they can be
protesters
they can put out a newspaper
they can have they're great at diplomacy
it turns out
they can't rule this country so
essentially the hospitals
and
the kind of healthcare infrastructure
is
being managed by ngos that are
international
um
but
most people had to leave
and and the taliban have impeded some of
that work
they told
adult women essentially to stay home
right so
a bit big part of the workforce isn't
there
so that i mean the supply chain is
it you know is kind of crawling to a
halt
trade with pakistan and its neighbors i
mean it's kind of a transit trade
economy
um it exports fruits
pakistan has been closing the border
because they're anxious about refugees
they want to
exert pressure on the international
community to recognize the taliban
because the pakistan want the taliban to
succeed in power because they see that
in pakistan's national interest
especially the london's rivalry with
with india
so the pakistan the pakistani security
institutions are playing a double game
essentially afghan people are being held
hostage and so
the taliban are also saying you know if
you don't recognize us
you're gonna let tens of millions of
afghans starve
so to which degree is taliban like
who
are the taliban what do they stand for
what do they want obviously year by year
this changes so what is the nature
of this organization can they be a
legitimate peaceful kind respectful
uh government
sort of holder of power or
or are they fundamentally
not capable of doing so yeah
i mean the briefest answer would be that
they are a
clerical
slash military organization um
they have
this is kind of a
imperfect metaphor but
years ago a german scholar used the term
caravan to describe them and that that
has some attractive elements because
different people have joined the taliban
for different purposes at different
times
but today
and people tell us you know scholars who
know more about the room than i have
said listen
the taliban is this kind of hodgepodge
of different actors and people and
competing interests
and i think
so we have a lot of scholars that listen
there they're it's polycentric
it's got people in
this city in that city and so on i think
actually
i was also skeptical how do they know
this i mean this is an organization that
doesn't
want you to know um where their money
comes from and so on
but i would say
now that we have a clearer picture of
what has happened
i'd say they are a astoundingly
well-organized
clerical military organization
that has a
very cohesive
and enduring ideology
which is quite idiosyncratic if we zoom
out and continue the conversation we're
having about islam and how we think
about radicalism and
you know who's drawn to what
um
people throw different terms
around to describe the taliban
some use the term that links it to
a kind of school of thought born in the
90's century in india the dobandi school
uh but if you look at their teachings
it's very clear now i think that
these labels it's like saying you know
you're an mit guy well what does that
mean i mean mit is home to
dozens of different potentially
kinds of
intellectual orientations right
i mean attaching the name of the school
doesn't quite capture
i mean
it's complicated i mean actually mit is
interesting because it's i would say mit
is different than stanford for example
yeah i think mit has a more kind of
narrow yeah um bad analogy in my part
maybe
well no it's interesting because i would
argue that there's some aspect of a
brand like taliban or mit yeah no
relation
that
has a kind of uh
interact like
the the brand results in the behavior of
the like enforces the kind of behavior
on the people and the people feed the
brand and like there's a loop i think
yeah stanford is a good example of
something that's more distributed
there's sufficient amount of diversity
in like all kinds of like centers and
all that kind of stuff that the the the
the the brand doesn't become one thing
yeah mit is so engineering it's yeah i i
think that okay so
scratching my teeth scratching for two
because i think stanford's more like mit
than than
than you might imagine but uh but isn't
talaban isn't it pretty
i don't think there's a diversity so
yeah right sorry so just a rephrase so
so people say oh the deobandi school i'm
like what is that i mean but the taliban
are
they're an ethnic movement
they represent
a vision of
pashtun power right passions are people
who
are quite internally diverse
actually
speak multiple dialects of pashto who
reside across the frontier of pakistan
and afghanistan
there are pashtuns who live all over the
planet right there's a community in
moscow california everywhere right so
it's a global diaspora of sorts
costumes have a kind of genealogical
imagination so that lots of pashtuns can
tell you the names of their grandparents
great-grandparents and so on and that's
kind of a there's a sense of pride in
that
posture language is a kind of
core element of that identity
but it's not universal so for example
you can meet people who say i am pashtun
but i don't know pashto
so as you as you claw away at this idea
it's amorphous it also means different
things different people at different
times so
saying the taliban our posh team
requires lots of qualifiers because lots
of passions will say no no i i have
nothing to tell on i hate those people
you know so
the taliban tried to mobilize other
pashtuns with limited success but their
core membership is almost exclusively
pashtun and they say
no no we represent afghans we represent
pious muslims and so in recent
two three years
they've gone further to say no we have
other ethnic groups we have uzbeks we
have tajiks
we have hazaras
and in the north of afghanistan in
recent years they did do a bit better at
drawing in people who were very
disappointed because of the government
and they were able to diversify their
ranks somewhat but if you want to say
august 15 and who they've appointed
what language they've used how they've
presented themselves it's clear that
you know they are poshtune they are male
and they
are extremely ideologically
cohesive
and
disciplined i'd say right so i think
that a lot of the polycentrism blah blah
some of that stuff was a way to fight a
war
um they are they are fundamentally you
know
a guerrilla movement
they see themselves as kind of
pious robin hoods
the rhetoric is very much about taking
from the rich taking from the privilege
giving to the poor
being on the side of the underdog
fighting against evil
and so
i mean their their bag if you like their
thing their central theme their brand is
about public morality and so their
origin story pretty much 1994 is that
they interceded they broke up a gang of
criminals
who were trying to rape people
and so there's a ranching kind of like
emphasis on like sexuality and on on
public morality
and really being the core of like you
know we're going to restore order and
public morality
and how that translates into governance
is something they've never sorted out i
mean how do you run a banking system if
your
intellectual priorities are really about
you know the length of a beard
and then and then their path to power
in a kind of abstract sense i mean a lot
of that was very much driven by um
if you like
propagating the problems of martyrdom
and that sounds i don't mean to say that
in a way that
to make it sound ridiculous may sound
like it's um
you know a moral judgment it's simply i
think a fact it's a fact of their appeal
that
they promised young men who have known
nothing else but
studying in certain schools if at all
but they've known fighting and they've
known they've known victimization and
this isn't i'm not asking for like
sympathy for them but i think the
reality is that a lot of the
we know about the kind of foot soldiers
is that they
they lost families and bombings um
in airstrikes in night raids
you know
i mean orphans have always been a stream
um
living in in all male society
uh not knowing girls not knowing women
hearing things from outside about places
like kabul and so there's always been
this kind of urban rural dimension it's
not it's not just that but
i think there's a
there's a whole imagination
that being taliban
captures
and the whole marginal thing is really
it's um
yeah i think to any religious person i
mean it's not a it's not a bizarre idea
i mean it animates i mean
so many global traditions yeah but i
think the
but you try to tell like an army colonel
right if you were to have a conversation
with you know u.s marine about this
i mean some would get it from their own
religious backgrounds but i think the
it it's an alien idea but i think it
it's essential to kind of stretch out
imaginations understand that's
that's attractive and now one of the
dilemmas going forward is that
they've got a pivot from
martyrdom and some have been some have
told foreign journalists i mean
it's good that we're in charge now we're
going to build a proper state
but i'm i it's kind of boring
um i want to keep fighting i want to
maybe i'll do it in pakistan yeah i mean
it's nice that they are expressing that
thought
some are not even honest sufficiently
with themselves to express that kind of
thought if you're
if you're a fighter
yeah it's a
you see that with a bunch of fighters or
professional athletes once they retire
yeah they don't know it's very it's
boring
yeah
and so like the if the spirit of the
taliban yeah
even the the best version of the taliban
is to fight is to be martyrs is to yeah
is to and the paint the world is good
and evil and you're fighting evil and
all that kind of stuff that's difficult
to imagine how they can run an education
system a banking system
respect
all kinds of citizens with different
backgrounds and religious beliefs and
women and
all that kind of stuff so yeah and
they've they've walked into kabul and
other major cities um
you know someone were young they didn't
know those places but also
the very important
obstacle for them is that afghan society
has changed i mean it's
it's not with even for the older guys
it's not what they knew in 1990s
um some always had some ambivalence
about you know the capital
but now it's totally different i mean
they've been shocked to see i think to
me one of the most striking
features of the last few weeks has been
that
you know women have come out on the
streets
and have stood their faces and said you
know we demand rights we demand
education we demand employment
and um these foot soldiers are
are paralyzed they're not sure they
don't know what to do with women period
yeah yeah and they don't know what to do
with being yelled at and having someone
stick their fingers in their faces i
mean this is not
not what they've imagined and so i think
and at this at this juncture there are
still foreign cameras around
so
they have committed acts of violence
against women against journalists
they've beaten people yeah they've
disappeared people even with cameras are
on even in this tense period yeah but i
think that when the cameras
you know retreat and that that stuff
could happen it's gonna get much worse i
think
so that the challenge now is you know
can the talbot rule and
and then this is where the diplomacy is
important because
the top one can't rule in isolation and
they know that and
part of the success is due to the fact
that they were
they became very good at talking to
other people
in the last
i mean it's been building the last
decade but that's the last five years
and they always have pakistan's backing
and so the taliban are we noted they're
a military force very effective
guerrilla force they beat they beat nato
i mean this is
still hasn't sunk in i mean the fact
that they
with light arms
using suicide attacks
using mines
improvise explosive devices
machine guns
and some in recent years they got sniper
rifles
and you know from the summer they got
american equipment on a broad scale
right
they have airplanes they have a lot that
they will be able to use eventually um
so but still basically it's a story of
ak-47s
some american small arms
and mines so it's very
ho chi minh
very old-school guerrilla fighting right
and they defeated the most powerful
military alliance in world history
probably so that has not yet sunk in
what that means for
american and global politics
um and now they're trying to rule right
they know they need
international support
and
their most consistent backers in
pakistan who sees them as a extension of
pakistani power
you know and this is very important for
a pakistani elite that of course is
looking toward india
they want to have their
rear covered right they want to make
sure that these pashtuns don't cause
trouble for pakistan
and they like i mean for some of the
security forces they like this vision of
the islamic state that the taiwan are
building there because they
those are not citizens from their views
of what pakistan should be but
the taliban have been
smart enough to kind of diversify their
potential international allies
so
everyone in the neighborhood has wanted
the u.s to leave right if we got 2001
the royal iranian and american special
forces in the north
working together against taliban to
displace them using
you know
iranian american and then afghan
resistance forces against the taliban
and that was a real moment of rape small
if we go back to that missed exits um
the relationship with iran could have
been different at that moment
but
the us under george w bush
you know devised this axis of evil
language
put them together with their enemy iraq
and north korea
all that went south um that was the
missed opportunity
um but in recent years the taliban and
iran have
kind of papered over the differences
they allowed the talbot to open some
offices
in on iranian territory
likely shared some resources some
intelligence some associated weaponry
um and then the taliban went to moscow
and for the administration
you know they've long been worried that
you know they see the taliban as a kind
of
you know disease that will potentially
move north
in fact uzbekistan tajikistan kyrgyzstan
turkmenistan and maybe creep into
russia's sphere of influence maybe
that's why they have you know
a bunch of troops sitting in tajikistan
i mean the one you know forward base
that russia still has in central asia is
in sunshine
and so the taliban were always
you know a worrying point but also
useful because
they could say well you know
um in case it's how long and out of
control we need to be here
and so tajikistan
said okay you know you're helping you're
helping secure us and
yes it impinges upon our sovereignty but
it's okay you know
so putin said you know
let's
you know give another black eye to the
americans
and let's
you know treat the taliban as if they're
the kind of government in waiting let's
have them come to moscow multiple times
this summer you know for the last year
or two they've been talking to the
talking to china right so the
photographs of
senior tablon figures
going from their office in qatar which
was a major major blow to the usb
government the fact that they were able
to open up an office in qatar that at
one point began to fly a flag of the
islamic afghanistan
that basically said we're a state in the
waiting
and as the u.s backed afghan government
failed and failed and failed at at
ruling two right as they showed how
corrupt they were
and as they really alienated more and
more afghans by committing backs of
violence against them
by stealing from them
by
you know basically creating a kind of
kleptocracy right
um
the taliban said we are pure
we are not corrupt
and look at us we're winning on the
battlefield and internationally look
we're talking to china we're talking to
putin we're talking to china yeah we're
a legitimate powerful center of central
asia and also kind of you know hinting
that you know we oh we have a website i
mean the whole digital angle is amazing
because they
they began to and this is important
actually they had a
website which
grew more so skated again after having
you know shot televisions and these kind
of ceremonial killings of these infidel
devices right
they said
we have a government we have commissions
we have a complaint line
they
lifted all this technocratic language
that you get from any un document you
know about good governance and all the
kind of you know generic language that
the ngo world has produced for us right
in english
they reproduce that in five languages on
their tablon website
and of course i'm not saying even
believe this but it was like
you know just put me in coach you know i
know the playbook i know how to run a
government and look we have a we have an
agricultural commission
we have um you know a taxation system
and and again this id and then on the
ground they had their own law courts
and they would creep into a district
assassinate some people the local
authority figures men of influence
um talk to local clerics either get them
on board or kill them
and say you know this date is corrupt
but we're bringing you justice this is
our calling card we're bringing public
reality and justice
and then
to a broader world
they said you know yeah things didn't go
perfectly the whole al-qaeda thing you
know
i wish we could have a do-over on that
um we're not going to let anyone hurt
you from our territory we just want to
rule and
people like us and and look
and so if you look at the neighborhood
iran even central asian states after a
while
recognizing they can make some money i
mean one of the one thing that spikes
down likes about the current arrangement
or they're not they're not hostile to is
that
they have all these contracts they can
potentially
make some money from
you know the pipeline dream remains
alive running natural gas oil to
you know which of the indian ocean
to markets you know beyond central asia
it's sitting on a couple trillion
dollars probably in mineral resources
that china would love to have of course
and so people looking at afghanistan now
after 20 years saying
you know under american rule it was a
basket case right
um there was a men's human suffering
incredibly violent
the world did not start counting
civilian casualties in afghanistan until
2009.
everything about that the war went on
for eight years
the talbot were never really defeated
they just went to pakistan they went to
the mountains into the woods
and so all these different american
operations as you noted
under bush obama trump and so on
um
killed
countless civilians the u.s never
accounted for that we never we never
even counted um
trump escalated civilian casualties by
escalating the air war
but a lot of this was like very ugly on
the ground you know night raid stuff or
you drop into a hamlet
and and massacre people
and then you're not honest about what
happened right so
that dynamic continued to
fuel the growth of taliban from below so
the foot soldiers they never they never
ran out of foot soldiers i mean the us
and its allies killed
tens of thousands maybe hundreds of
thousands of tailbone fighters over the
last 20 years
but they just sprouted up again
and part of that was the kind of
solidarity culture the male bonding of
of of martyrology of you know of
martyrdom and of enough
you know revenge and a sense of um you
know the foreign invader
and i've heard i mean i've you know i
haven't taught a ton of
us military people but through the
hoover you know they put officers in our
classes sometimes and
met a few wonderful you know army and
marine officers who i really enjoyed you
know we came from the south like me
always had great rapport with them and
and they expressed a range of opinions
about this i think that you know i
learned a lot from someone who said yeah
i mean i get that i get why they hate us
i get why
they're still fighting because
you know last week
we just
killed 14 of their you know fellow
villagers
so
the officers the guys on the ground you
know fighting this war
we're not stupid about that i mean they
they got the human dimension of that and
yet no one got off the exit as you said
people people kept driving
um
but going forward now internationally
it's critical that they have
i mean they've had meetings i mean what
the hell have done since august 15th is
a lot of diplomacy they've had meetings
they've had people they've had tashkent
come they've had beijing come they've
had moscow come
i mean they've had
major visits from
islamabad from security people from
diplomatic circles
and they're counting on
things being different this time i mean
the first time around the only people
who backed the taliban by recognition
giving them automatic recognition with
the saudis pakistanis and the uae and
because of al qaeda
because of opium
because of some of the human rights
stuff you know the u.s pushed everyone
to like you know let's not recognize the
state even though the us did i mean
colin powell famously
in the summer of 2001
you know we did give a few grants and
aid um
to the taliban
as i kind of like massaging negotiations
they kept talking about bin laden but i
also wanted him to stop um opium
production i mean afghanistan throughout
all this period we've talked about is
the global center of
opium production i mean over the years
more and more
of the afghan economy continue to today
is devoted to the opium trade
which is
uh the thing that leads to heroin
uh some of the painkillers yeah
and even if afghan poppies don't make it
to
you know hoboken you know that they're
not the
the source of american deaths you know
they are part of a
a universal market a global market which
you know i think any economist will tell
you is part of the story of our opium
you know problem
something i
read
maybe a decade ago now and i just kind
of looked it up again to bring it up to
see your opinion on this is um there's a
2010 report by the international council
on security development that showed that
92 percent
of afghans in
helmand and kandahar province
know nothing of the 9 11 attacks on u.s
in 2001.
is this at all representative of what
you know
is this possible so basically put
another way
it
is it possible that a lot of afghans
don't even know
the reason
why there may be troops or the
sort of american
provided narrative for why there's
troops
so american soldiers and american drones
overhead
in uh afghanistan right i mean my gut
response not knowing the details of this
actual poll is
that that's a um
a very
unhelpful way to think about
how afghans relate to the world and i
think um
you know it could be you know if you go
to my hometown
in north carolina
if you knock on some doors
you may meet people who don't know all
kinds of things i could probably walk
around this neighborhood here in
california and there'd be all kinds of
people who
don't know all kinds of things um
you know kyrie irving
apparently thinks the earth is flat i
mean you know
so we could we could
make a lot of
certain kinds of ignorance i think but i
think what i would say and then and
there's also i mean a companion point
may be that
in thinking about the withdrawal the
collapse the return of the taliban
there's been
a big conversation about um
you know what afghans think of us really
and
this famous piece in the new yorker was
about
how you know many people liked the
taliban
you know that many women
interviewed
supposedly in this piece um
you know were sympathetic because they
lost family members and all the violence
and the idea kind of was that
you know we haven't thought about that
at all when in fact you know of course
we have and lots of people have but i
think if you're just dropping into the
conversation
if you look at like the media arc of
coverage of afghanistan the united
states i mean
the
arc went from lots of coverage during of
course 9 11 it's aftermath
lots of coverage during obama's surge
and then quickly dropped down
the last decade has been almost nothing
so if you ask the same question about
americans or other americans i'm not
sure what they would say to you what
percentage would actually know
why the us is in x y or z either right
but on the afghan side just return to
that for a moment i think that
you know we can fetishize these
provinces they are kind of you know a
place where taliban's support has been
greatest
also where there's been the most
violence where the americans have been
most committed to trying to
root out the taiwan movement where
hellman
yeah it's mostly poshtune not
exclusively but mostly poshtune you know
mostly rural what is it
that's the other group you know that
that the taliban claimed to represent
right
so they're this group what other groups
are yeah okay sorry yeah sorry so in
cities you'll find
everything right that is in afghanistan
you'll find uzbeks tajiks hazaras
um these are people who
you know it's like a turkey language
right uh most uzbekists live in what is
now uzbekistan but they form majorities
in some northern parts of the city i'm
sorry of the country of afghanistan
but what it emphasizes that um
and you can you can find online an
ethographic map afghanistan and you'll
see
green where pashtuns live red where
hazaras live
orange these bikes live you know purple
where tajiks live
then there are a bunch of other smaller
groups of different kinds you know there
are
um
[Music]
there are baluch
there are indifferent religious
communities there are sunni shia
different kinds of shia what are the key
differences between them is it a
religious basis
from the origins of where they
immigrated from and how different are
they yeah so they're all
i mean they're all indigenous i think i
mean there's a kind of mythology that
some groups have been there longer right
so they have a greater claim to power
but
historically
i mean it's like you know other groups
anywhere people have different
narratives about themselves but many
many pashtuns would tell you not all but
many would say
we are the kind of state builders of
afghanistan the dynasty that ruled much
of the space
that was born in the mid 18th century
that ruled until 1973 more or less
generalizing
you know was a pakian dynasty the
taliban have definitely said
to some audiences we are the rightful
rulers because we are pashtun
um
the trick though is let me i don't mean
to be evasive but just to get based on
the complexity
um one quick answer as well the majority
of minorities i mean one finds out a lot
along with those maps
but i would say
suspend any firm belief in that because
that could be entirely wrong in fact
there's never been a modern sense of
census of afghanistan
so when journalists say
passions are a majority or they're the
biggest group i would say not so fast
i would say not so fast because of
migration is one major issue
no major
um modern census
actually the soviets got pretty close
but didn't quite you know find something
comprehensive and didn't publicize it
knowing that it was
um you know modern times ethnicity can
be the source of political mobilization
it's not it's not innately so but it's
been part of the story but then you have
mixed families right so a lot of people
you'll meet you'll encounter in the asp
run around i mean well
um i am you know my my one parent is
one is one is pashtun right or i'm
pashtun as i mentioned before but i
don't speak pashto right
or i am hazara but
you read about us is as she has ours in
fact i'm a sunni hizara or i'm a secular
hazara or i'm an atheist to zara i mean
everything's possible right
um
one of my friends
if you if he were here he'd say i'm
kabuli
you know i'm i'm from kabul so
if you think about the russian terms you
know it means a lot if you're a mosquito
you know if you're from bishop or yeah
i mean you know yeah well
even here there's bostonians yep that's
right texans
californians
yeah east coast west coast all that
stuff
those are all part of the mix here so
you ask about kandahar and helmand then
i would say
yeah if you go out to
you know a pomegranate
you know field
you'll meet a guy who
may reckon time differently from you and
me
who
may not be literate he may not have ever
had a geography lesson
but if you go one door over you may meet
a guy
who
[Music]
you know whose life path has taken him
to live in you know six countries
he may speak five languages
and these are all things i'm not saying
they're all these are just because
people have money and go fly around i
mean they're people who are displaced by
war
from late 1970s right even already in
the early 70s people were traveling by
the tens of thousands to iran you know
as labor migrants and once you get to
iran once you get to pakistan once you
get to uzbekistan
you then connect to all kinds of
cosmopolitan cultures in fact i think
one of the themes of of the book you
know that you may or may not have read
and they put you to sleep um
you know afghan modern was about you
know conceptualizing afghanistan as a
cosmopolitan place where
for centuries people went on the move
and trade in this area you think of you
know i think this mischaracterization of
places like helmand
and kandahar you fly in
or you're part of the marine battalion
and you see people there and they look
different
and i think in our imagination
if i can generalize you know they look
like they've been there for millennia
right the dress or whatever right you
think of technology you think of the
the mud compounds and so on you think of
you know
animal drawn
transportation that kind of stuff right
or the motorbike right at most is what
they have
but in fact if you follow those families
um
their trade has taken them to northern
india for centuries right the trade is
connected them to
cospalton centers yes say they have a
scholar in the family that scholar may
have studied all of the middle east
south asia right
you know their ancestors may have been
horse traders who went all the way to
moscow right i mean we we have
historical records of all these people
traveling across eurasia
pursuing all kinds of livelihoods
and so afghanistan is this paradox of
visually looking remote and looking like
it's kind of stuck in time
but the family trajectories and the
current contradictories are astoundingly
cosmopolitan and mobile
and so um and a conception of being a
world center is also quite strong so
you know another way to frame that
question about like do the know about
911 be like why should we know about 911
because we are at the center of
something important right we are the
center of asia we are the heart of asia
we have a kind of historic greatness we
are
you know
a proud culture of our own achievements
right so we're not worried about that
right
that said i mean sure there are
different narratives about why americans
are there why people are being killed
you know
of course you'd find you know they want
to convert us you know they want our
gold they want our opium they want x y z
right there was a recent story about a
taliban
official
sitting in office in kabul and a
journalist asked them can you find in
this rotating globe
find your country find where we sitting
right now and he was filmed not being
able to do it and so a lot of you know
racist kid afghans with asperger were
saying you know ha ha look at this and
if that exists i mean i think
i could go to my stanford classroom and
there'd be a lot of kids who wouldn't
know where afghanistan is too right but
but i i wouldn't i wouldn't use those
metrics to suggest that this is a
a place that doesn't have a sense of its
place in the world and of
geopolitics i think if anything being a
relatively small country in a very
complicated neighborhood
i mean everybody every cab driver i mean
people have a i mean
you know this is where america is
different because i don't think
americans have this sense you know we're
talking about moscow and stuff i think
you know
moscow cab drivers
i think a lot of them are going to tell
you like what's happening in the world
and why right and it's just part of it's
part of their thing right you find that
in ghana you find that mexico city right
you find that lots of places so i think
afghans are part of
a very sophisticated kind of
mapping of the world and where they fit
in
and a lot of them remarkably had done it
firsthand which is what struck me so
much and you know relating my
experiences from the 1990s and touchdown
places that these guys had already lived
in more countries than i've ever been
they already knew half those languages i
mean
this one friend's russian was impeccable
um and of course it helped they had
russian girlfriends
they had you know they they mixed with
the police they had run-ins i mean they
this wasn't something you got from a
book right this was like hard knock life
i mean one one friend was from a wealthy
family
uh in this trading diaspora
and he was imprisoned i mean they sent
him to prison uh in pakistan and he
talks about how he can start like
running
running in the jail you know
taking cigarettes to people doing little
things and
kind of you know it's
these are not stories of like i went to
i went to harvard and so i'm so learning
because of this i mean it's it's a whole
range of experiences the interesting
thing is the survey is a survey and
it doesn't
reflect ignorance as you're saying
perhaps
but it may reflect a different
geopolitical view of the world than the
west has
yeah so if
you know for a lot of the world 911
was one of the most important moments of
recent human history
and for
afghanistan not to know that especially
when they're part of that story yeah
means they have a very different like uh
there's there could be a lot of things
said one is the spread of information
is different the channels of the way
information is spread
and to the things they care about maybe
they see themselves
in uh as part of a longer arc of history
with the bickering of these
superpowers they seem to want to go to
the moon are not as important as the big
sort of arc that's been the story of
afghanistan
it is you know that that's an
interesting idea but um it's still a bit
if at all representative of the truth
right it's heartbreaking
that they're not
do not see themselves as a
active player
in this
game between the united states and uh
in central asia because they're such a
critical player and they feel and
obviously
um in many ways get the short end of the
stick in this whole interaction with uh
uh you know invasion of afghanistan for
many years and then uh this uh rushed
with withdrawal of troops and and now
the economic uh collapse and that yeah
it's um
it's it's sad in some ways no it's right
it's true i mean you know another way to
put it is this um
i mean there's a range of knowledge and
and you're right the information flows
are are
are
peculiar to particular geographies and
histories and stuff and i think that you
know plucking out one sample from some
fairly remote area
for one like follow the follow the
agricultural products i mean
and this is where you know i think
urban rural divides sure used to mean a
lot more
in the 19th century right so a lot of
like nuts and bolts of history is about
conceiving of these
kinds of distinctions you know but i
think that
if one has the privilege of traveling a
bit you see that like
urban areas are fed by rural interlands
and if you look think of who actually
you know brings the bread the milk you
know the pomegranates and so on it
creates these networks and then
you know mobility
channels information and so on
but yeah but your broader point about
like the tragedy of this man i guess if
i can quote a brain student of mine an
afghan american woman who just received
her phd who's now you know doctor
um he's a great scholar
you know we've done
several events now trying to just think
through what's happened and
before she's very emotionally affected
by it and she continues to ask a really
great question if i can get her phrasing
right
you know if you think of the cycle of
like the top one being in power in 2001
in the way in which that affected women
in particular you know half african half
of society right
then you think of this 20th period of
violence and
and you know missed exits right and
repeated tragedy
that also it created a space i mean it
created space for a whole i'd say
generationally it created a sense a
space for
people to realize something new i think
so we have to attend to the the dynamism
of the society right so
yeah this happened mostly in kabul other
big cities mazar sharif herat
but you can't limit your analysis to
that because things like radio
television
everyone got a tv channel there's a
wonderful documentary called afghan star
that i recommend to your listeners and
viewers that it's about a singing show a
scene contest show
but you see just just personal things
about like connections i mean
it's a it's a show by an independent
you know television network that did
drama it did it did kind of infomercials
for the government and
huge american investment in it so it
wasn't politically neutral but it did
talk shows did all this kind of stuff
but it did the singing show that became
you know incredibly popular
modeled upon the british american you
know american idol kind of stuff you
know and you can vote so i had a kind of
democratic practice element
but it's fascinating to see that you
know
people hooked up generators to
televisions and watch this you know you
think of like
literacy rates literacy rates are
imperfect and you know people who study
you know
medieval modern europe talk about how
yeah no one could read
and there weren't many books but if
someone had a book it'd be read aloud to
a whole village potentially or gathering
so there wasn't much you know some of
these metrics don't get what people
actually
perceive as information or exposure
because
there's the magnifying power of open
spaces and
hearing radio and group settings seeing
television group settings
having telephone
you know cheap cell phones which then
become an access point to the world and
social media right so
all the stuff swept across african
society as it did elsewhere you know um
in the last decade or more
so afghan society became
you know in important ways really
connected to everything going on and so
you see that reflected politically and
what people wanted so you had some
people obviously
back to return to the taliban
some people wanted sasquatch
but increasingly many more people wanted
something else um
and one of the great failures was to
expose people to democracy
but only give them the rigged version
and so the us and the state department
in particular
continued to double down on faked
elections for the parliament and for the
presidency in afghanistan what kind of
elections faked fraudulent elections for
parliament and and for
president
in afghanistan again and again from the
very beginning
and those last these elections
were partly theater for the us right for
remaining on the road that you're
describing right for not deviating for
not exiting because we were building
democracy there
in reality the us government knew it was
never really building democracy there it
was establishing control
and elections were one means to gather
control right but then you had on the
ground especially when young people
going to university
you know having experiences that
were denied to them before
you know they took these problems
seriously so part of the disengagement
that we see today
is that you know
they believe what the u.s told them that
they're constructing democracy and of
course you know centers like us may be
thinking well you know you're not really
doing that you're backing fraud they
believed it when they were younger and
now they're actually smart enough to
understand that it's a farce yeah
but and so indirectly had the
consequence of actually working
yeah and that it taught the young
over a period of 20 years young folks to
believe
that democracy is possible and then to
realize what democracy is not exactly
that's the currency that's duplicated
and so
but not but now look at us now it's you
know it's
now november
and so
this whole
period and i wouldn't say like you know
i wouldn't cast the last 20 years if
we're looking at all the achievements
you know
i wouldn't
put them in an american tally sheet like
oh this something we should pat
ourselves on the back for i think that
much just happened actually against what
the americans wanted i mean the kind of
free thinking
democracy wanting
i mean even like yeah we could point you
out on the religious religious sphere i
mean
the
afghan religious landscape became very
pluralistic
um lost young people wanted a different
kind of secular politics
um
but the old the old guard who wanted the
status quo and wanted something that
they fought for in 1980s
tended to still get american backing as
the political leads who still tended to
monopolize political power
um so all stuff was happening in
different ways
i mean the americans established this
american university of afghanistan which
is i think one of the best things the
u.s did there and i regret that
the us didn't fund 20 more you know
sprinkling them across the country
making them accessible people because it
was
it was you know again it wasn't an
engine of americanization
it was just opportunity and so that the
thirst for higher education was really
extraordinary it was never never really
met the us tended to put money in
primary education which much of that too
was was fraudulent
but so you have all this interesting
dynamism you have you know the arts you
have
a critical space i mean i call it a
public sphere in the classic
european sense you know the afghans made
of their own and
again it wasn't americanization it
wasn't
imposed
it was something that afghans built
across generations but really with a
firm foundation among youth
who wanted importantly a multi-ethnic
afghan society you asked about pashtuns
and that kind of stuff and a lot of that
language in recent years was um
they were aware that the us-backed
government was playing ethnic politics
and trying to kind of put people in the
blocks and mobilize people based on
their ethnic identity
and there was a younger cohort of people
who said you know we are afghan
and there's interesting social media
stuff where people say i am hazara but
i'm also tajik i'm also uzbek
i mean
it was a way of creating a multi-ethnic
afghan national identity
that embraced everything i mean very
utopian you know super utopian right
but symbolically it's very important
that they rejected
being mobilized politically
you know voting as a hazara or voting is
whatever and of course there were there
were communities who wanted to you know
vote as that ethnic community but there
are also people who said you know let's
put a kind of civic nationalism first
one that accommodates i think pluralism
in a way that rejected a kind of
majoritarian politics of
one ethnic group dominating the thing
so all this stuff was quite interesting
i mean women were asserting themselves
in across you know multiple spheres
of course it remained patriarchal of
course there were struggles of course
there's violence of course you know
there's no utopia
um but the door and all that shut
in on august 15
so to go back to the quote that i wanted
to
offer from
the student um now professor
was it you know and trying to make sense
of this
and you mentioned the tragic
arc here um
you think the 20 years like
she asked you why did you go to war in
our country
basically why did you do this house for
20 years when this was never about us
you never asked us if you wanted to come
you never asked us what you wanted to
build here
you'd ask us when you're coming and you
didn't ask us when when you're leaving
you just did this all on your own
and we tried to make the most of it
and then you pulled the rug out from
under us you know at the 11th hour
and returned returned to power
partly by diplomacy
it wasn't
at the end just a military loss i mean
it was a
series of body decisions i mean the idea
you asked about alternatives i mean
giving up bagram i mean holding to the
timeline
i mean the biden people did not need to
hold to
the doha agreement that trump had signed
i mean every american president writes
his or her own foreign policy right so
the body administration acted as if and
they tried to convince us that their
hands were tied
um and that it was either this or 21
years of war or some absurd kind of you
know
false
alternative and so but i think that's
important for american audiences to hear
that you know they're like you came to
here to experiment
you came here to
punish you came here to kind of
reassert
you know your dominance the world stage
you know to work out the the fear and
and hurt of 9 11 that we talked about
which was so real you know and palpable
um and it's important for american
politics since then like you did you
worked out your problems you know on us
on our
territory and
now what do we have for it you know and
then the people who
who had a stake in in that system
imperfect as it was
have been desperate to leave
and so this i don't know how much people
wear this but
you know i'm a scholar i work in
california you know
i have friends i
edit a journal on afghanistan and
you know but i'm not a politician i'm
not a soldier
but people assume that
you know afghans have been desperately
trying to reach me and anyone who is
kind of on the radar as an american
to help get them out you know that's the
kind of like
you know the symbol of voting with your
feet you know is quite powerful i mean
they
there's a huge swath of society that
doesn't want the system and is
literally living in terror about it
and actually women you know i mean
especially women of certain age i mean
they feel like their lives are over i
mean there is an epidemic of suicide
um
they feel betrayed and
and some people have done some good
things and getting people out you know i
mean some
you know the u.s military vets have been
you know at the forefront of
working to get out people you know that
that they
they know they owe
but um the u.s government doesn't want
these people i mean they have created
all these obstacles to
to allowing a safety valve for people to
leave
you